Jeremy want to talk about just what it
was like to create these familial bonds
that really provide the backbone of the
movie we were really lucky to have some
time uh in in Baton Rouge together
before we started filming that time
together really provided a sort of like
a shorthand to a kind of intimacy and
and and and trust that that might not
have been there otherwise but when we
first got into the ring I think I I was
feeling pretty foolish and then I
realized we we were kind of all in the
same boat in that way also the the
structure of filming you know the
beginning of the film process was was
mostly at the home the childhood home of
the the Von Erics and we got to know one
another through that that process as
well before more of the like brutality
and and and tragedy sort of like set in
you know